bonsoir bonsoir donc vous êtes grand
reporter spécialiste de politique
étrangère auteurs de la guerre du golfe
le dossier secret en collaboration avec
pierre salinger auteur de tempête du
désert et de la guerre des bouches dont
vous nous avez parlé sur ce plateau
c'est là que vous avez annoncé que le
grand père bush avait fait du business
avec les nazis et puis aussi que les
bush était en affaire avec des proches
de ben laden le livre s'est bien vendu
j'imagine parce qu'il y avait quand même
du biscuit deux ans ah oui non s'est
très bien vendu et il s'est rendu
également dans 19 pays ah ouais mais
sauf aux états unis il s'est rendu en
chine rustrel il a été baissée l'ère des
salaires en allemagne oui mais non plus
propres aux états unis votre nouveau
livre s'appelle le monde secret de
bouche
[Musique]
alors la question que vous posez lancé
avec laurent intéresse tout le monde la
question c'est qui gouverne réellement
l'amérique voilà un alors ça commence
avec l'élection de double you une
élection contestable avec
337 milles 576 vote deux mois que le
perdant le point de départ de cette
enquête que j'ai menée aux états unis
s'étaient en effet ça cette élection qui
était étrange controversé et dans
laquelle j'ai découvert que notamment
deux juges de la cour suprême qui ont
fait basculer le vote en faveur donc de
george deubeuliou bush étaient des
proches à la fois de la famille bush et
l'autre aussi été mêlé à des milieux
d'extrême droite donc élections
contestables et contestées est ce que
vous racontez dans votre livre de plus
grave c'est que le jeune bouche double
you a vaincu son complexe par rapport à
son père et sa dépendance à l'alcool
grâce à la bible et depuis c'est un
illuminé quoi jésus dit qu'il est sans
penseurs préféré sa mère le prend pour
moïse enfin c'est très inquiétant vos
envies votre truc oui non le vrai
problème c'est que le seul livre le
premier lit il faut que georges de l'ubo
chez lui de la première à la dernière
ligne cnet c'est à l'âge de 39 ans la
bible mais dans des conditions assez
précis c'est qu'en effet il traversé une
crise une crise personnelle graville
buzet son money son ménage battait de l
aile et donc il y avait un de ses amis
qui traverse également une grande
difficulté un texan comme lui et qui est
aujourd'hui au ministre du commerce
et pendant deux ans ses hommes se
sont-ils deux hommes qui aujourd'hui on
n'est pas stoecklé sont immergés dans en
effet donc la lecture attentive de la
bible et doux bush est ressorti
transfiguré en disant j'ai trouvé un ami
en la personne de jésus il est là
d'ailleurs dit peu après juste après son
annonce entrer à la maison blanche il a
dit un groupe en effet donc de
responsables religieux il a dit vous
savez je suis persuadé que dieu a une
mission pour moi hôtes allemands je ne
serai pas là je serai dans un bar du
texas et non pas dans le bureau ovale et
art ce qui est plus grave évidemment
c'est l'entourage alors il ya beaucoup
d' illuminé autour de lui un bon coup
qu'ils croient au retour de l'antéchrist
au retour du messie en forme et dans un
délire absolu oui moi ce qui m'a
intéressé est ce que j'ai trouvé
fascinant dans cette enquête c'est qu'au
fur et à mesure que j'avançais on
trouvait en effet les personnages qui
sont des personnages extrêmement
inquiétant qui croit en effet que nous
sommes à la veille de la fin du monde
alors on pourrait penser que ce sont des
marginaux sont entre 15 et 18 millions
donc des lecteurs qui soutiennent
georges de bellio bouge et qui sont des
chrétiens fanatiques opposé mais
absolument opposé à tout ce qui est en
effet
libéralisation des moeurs évidemment
avortement n'en parlons pas contrôler
l'aide aux pauvres aux déshérités aux
faibles car ils ont une haine farouche
pour les faibles ou plus vraiment bon et
sur l'autre séance à qui s'en va très
chrétien 804 chrétiens et sur l'autre
versant ils ont une fascination
également parce qu'ils pensent que c'est
là justement la terre du jugement
dernier il ya une fascination pour
israël parce qu'ils pensent que nous
sommes à la veille de la nouvelle
armageddon est l'antéchrist est déjà sur
terre ils le disent il est déjà sur
terre nous sommes entrés dans la lutte
du bien et du mal et il va y avoir
bientôt le retour en effet donc du
messie mais un messi qui sera chrétiens
et semer cyr et instaurera le royaume de
dieu mais alors évidemment ne survivront
nous survivrons dans leur logique que
les vrai qu'il ya des vrais chrétiens
jésus
remettez-vous et les juifs ni les
musulmans et comme le disait d'ailleurs
un observateur juifs mais vous savez
c'est une pièce qui ne consomment pas
tellement parce que c'est une pièce car
cinq actes auxquels les juifs
disparaissent au quatrième as oui mais
voilà alors effectivement il ya beaucoup
de chrétiens sionistes comme vous les
appelez donc c'est le thème qu'on leur
donne autour d'eux au tour de george
bush alors est ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui que l'exécutif américain est
sous influence c'est un exécutif qui est
sous influence et en même temps c'est un
exécutif qui est d'un cynisme incroyable
parce que c'est véritablement le
principe fait ce que je faisais ce que
je dis mais pas ce que je suis c'est à
dire que par exemple vous avez donc des
déclarations qui ont été faites par le
vice président américain dick cheney et
dick cheney avant de devenir
vice-président était le pdg de la plus
grande société de services pétroliers au
monde qui s'appelle halliburton et
halliburton sa société alors qu'il en
était le président a violé donc et
tournai l'embargo sur l'irak pour vendre
du matériel pétrolier saddam hussein est
aussi l'exemple extraordinaire du
ministre en effet delà des dumistes à
des sens monsieur rumsfeld et monsieur
comme celle dont qui a été au conseil
d'administration d'un énorme groupe qui
s'appelle abb qui est un groupe à la
fois suisse et et suédois en l'an 2000
2000 approuvé la vente par ce groupe
donc à la corée du nord de deux
centrales nucléaires deux centrales des
pays décrit comme axe du mal alors est
ce que en disant ça en disant que
finalement aux etats unis aujourd'hui il
ya une forte influence de ce que vous
appelez les chrétiens sionistes qui sont
des alliés objectifs en tous les cas du
likoud pour le moment tous les cas en
disant qu autour de george bush il ya
beaucoup de juifs qui sont liées au
likoud est ce que vous prenez pas de
risque d'alimenter la théorie du grand
complot juif mondial certainement pas je
m'en voudrais bien donc bien entendu non
non non il n'en est pas question mais
vous dites quand même que dans le clan
des faucons les pro-israéliens le 11
septembre était une opportunité c'est
une partie de rien venu pour mettre en
pratique leur politique et que la guerre
directe n'est qu'un premier pas en fait
par rapport à un remodelage du moyen
orient mais regardez aujourd'hui la
polémique qui se développe sur les armes
de destruction massive sur le fait qu'on
ne les trouve pas sur les faits qu'on
est en effet donc sciemment probablement
menti et certains défauts qu'on le
reconnaisse ouvertement avec une espèce
de cynisme tranquille en effet on a
choisi la solution qui pouvait rallier
la plus large opinion way c'est comme
tout à fait étonnant on a menti au
peuple et la guerre on est même si
l'idée voix de faux rapports 16 ans
exactement aujourd'hui à washington a
menti au peuple américain en 2000 menti
à l'opinion internationale
mais aujourd'hui c'est comme
extraordinaire la mise en condition à
travers la presse justement dont qui à
travers un certain nombre de télévision
notamment la chaîne du magna multi
milliardaire rupert murdoch qui est très
proche des bouches est telle que les
américains 43 % des américains sont
persuadés qu'on a quand même trouvé les
armes de destruction massive à
l'intérieur du territoire irakien est
extraordinaire mais d'ailleurs paul
wolkowitsky était inquiète un faucon
incarner au conservateur a déclaré
récemment dans vanity fair que les armes
de destruction massive était en fait une
raisons bureaucratiques que c'est une
invention complète même lui le dit dans
un journal qui est certes réservé à
l'élite américaine mais qui vient de
publier aux états unis a reçu un oui
mais bien sur l'a10 cynisme mais quel
cynisme oui mais vous savez c'est un
ancien foutu de votre gueule on vous le
disent pas grave voilà il faut ajouter
une composante aussi quelle
extraordinaire et que j'ai découvert
semoun fameux secte moon est le
fondateur de la secte moon son est très
proches très très proches vraiment de
bush il a soutenu donc de george
deubeuliou bouge il a soutenu le bush
père lorsqu'il s'est présenté à la
présidence et bush père accepte de faire
des conférences pour moon à travers le
monde et pour les organisations de moon
à travers le monde est payé ce ailleurs
ce bien qu'il soit millionnaire payer
100 milles le dollar l'heure et il ya
une espèce d'alliance extraordinairement
contre nature entre cette extrême droite
fanatiques et moon qui est une secte
dangereuse c'est qu'elle est interdite
dans nombreux pays ça fout le ferez sans
nom mais ça fait flipper ouais
franchement qui est bien c'est
à prendre où tu sors plus de chez toi
le grand père bush is et du business
avec les nazis et oui ils ne soutiennent
désormais oui oui bien sûr c'est ça qui
font le bourdon élections en forme en
déformant un nom c'est ça qui est
effrayant et il y a un un certain nombre
de relais dans la presse et dans dans la
télévision et dans les journaux qui ont
servi effectivement donc efficacement
donc à à relier à la française et ses
idées parce que quand je dis à la
bataille des idées il y a ce que je
raconte il ya un certain nombre de
fondations d'extrême droite notamment
est un personnage fascinant et un
personnage qui s'appelle skf mellon
caisse mais l'enquêté le premier
d'ailleurs à financer les mellon c'est
la famille la plus riche des états unis
et avec les avec les rockefeller et les
mellon donc sont des banquiers
procéderez fait donc des dents intérêts
dans le pétrole skf mellon est une
espèce de personnages qui n'espère de
milliardaires qui vit reclus totalement
reclus et à pittsburgh et il a utilisé
son immense fortune plus d'un milliard
de dollars pour financer des
institutions qui sont aujourd'hui des
institutions qui ont l'esprit sont
installés donc depuis créé depuis 20 ans
et qui ont totalement remodelé le
paysage social c'est-à-dire qu'il a en
effet mais je veux dire par exemple au
niveau des moeurs
ils ont lancé une véritable bataille
contre les pauvres une véritable
bataille de deux hommes dans en faveur
du racisme et d'art ségrégation il ya
par exemple les penseurs américains donc
aujourd'hui les plus les plus connus qui
explique qu'il faut voix beau lire
l'acte sur l'égalité raciale et 1964
donc c'est bien il me dit clairement et
qu'on a le droit en effet deux on
devrait avoir le droit de discriminer
aussi bien donc en matière d'emploi
qu'en matière de logement c'est une
guerre qui a été lancé et je veux dire
de camp jeudi et que ces milliards qui
étaient lancées contre les faits contre
les pauvres par tous ces gens et cetera
donc nous on explique par exemple il ya
un homme qui a financé un livre et une à
une organisation qui ont financé un
livre qui s'appelle loathing grande bon
peu importe et qui a été une bible pour
tous les ultra conservateurs noter on
explique que la pauvreté s'est traduit
au crise économique c'est de nature des
gens cc du pcc sont cons il fallait en
gros c'est ça et le type a récidivé
après l'es10 voilà on a voulu trop aider
les pauvres d'entre les pauvres on a
fabriqué beaucoup encore beaucoup trop
de pauvres et il a récidivé après avec
un autre livre s'appelle de belle cure
qui a été lancé par cette organisation
ultra conservatrice qui était halle des
livres de chevet aussi le jazz de blues
bouge dans lequel il explique la cette
fois ci que en fait l'inégalité donc
d'intelligence ou fin d'audience
différence de cuir résulte en effet donc
des races d'eric laurent c'est quand
même excusez moi une vision est claire
yens du monde nothing day d hubert
mansion et des surhommes annoncée de la
vision d'hitler c'est tout à fait
étonnant c'est une vision absolument
totalement repenser l'idée que nous nous
nous avons america mais absolument -
l'amérique mes parents m'expliquer quand
ils sont arrivés en 44 qui nous ont
libérés et aujourd'hui être obligé de se
coller dans le cigare qui sont devenus
carrément d'après ce que vous dites
enfin pas tous certes mais pas tous en
soule et 4 ces mecs-là des quasi
hitlérien c'est terrible à imaginer
alors est ce qu'on peut dire éric
laurent comme norman mailer dansant dans
son dernier livre que l'amérique
finalement est passée la démocratie l
empire oui bien sûr et cette vision
impérialistes s'accompagne d'une vision
arrogante par exemple envers la france
ouais je veux dire la manière dont en
effet on nous sommes mis en travers du
chemin j'ai donc de des décisions
américaines a été quelque chose qui
était totalement vous regardez et
d'ailleurs on est allé jusqu'au point de
par exemple d'utiliser et de réécrire
les la marseillaise
voulait que vous le dise oui à c'est
tout à fait étonnant c'est tout à fait
étonnant tout apporté non non j'ai tout
apporté par hasard non parce que c'est
tout à fait étonnant quand même et c'est
décrit par un organe des
néoconservateurs américains c'est à dire
que c'est pas du tout un organe vraiment
bas de gamme et ses terrasses étaient
écrits par monsieur qui s'appelle
christophe et la nouvelle marseillaise
donc à aller paroles suivantes allons
enfants de la patrie rendons-nous encore
détester nous approchons chaque tyrannie
avec la même servilité nous brillons à
la servilité
l'amerloque demande assistance mais nous
rions dans son visage bien sûr c'est
notre héritage deux points plus tard
nous joindrons la résistance george bush
est un sauvage mais la france a plus de
fromage marchons marchons faisons parade
de nos prétentions quelqu un qu est-ce
qui a écrit ça un monsieur qui s'appelle
christol et qui les sols william kristol
et la voici
lol
oh
oui
non s'il vous plaît bonsoir excusé
vallès-bled bonsoir excuser les cris qui
vous ont accueilli monsieur christian
que c'est à cause de la marseillaise on
va essayer de discuter tranquillement
vous avez 50 ans vous êtes directeur
d'être de madère oui puis standard
vous êtes un intellectuel
néoconservateurs le plus en vue
d'ailleurs des néoconservateurs le
parent on pourrait donner aux
conservateurs vous animez un think tank
un réservoir de penser une cellule de
réflexion qui s'appelle projet pour un
nouveau siècle américain avec votre amie
laurence caplanne voilà dans l'est qui
d'ailleurs vous cosigné un livre qui
s'appelle notre route commence à bagdad
et c'est aux éditions saint-simon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors est ce qu'on peut dire william
kristol que le 11 septembre a permis aux
états unis a autorisé finalement aux
états unis un coup d'état un coup d'état
pacifique certes mais un coup d'état néo
conservateurs
n'ont pas dire ça vous dire que george
bush a dit le président avant le 20
septembre il l'est toujours après le 11
septembre et des élections normales en
novembre 2002 comme ça il n'y a pas eu
de coup d'état aux états unis
malheureusement j'ai le regret de dire
ça reste une démocratie comme la france
alors je vais essayer d'expliquer un
petit peu vos idées william kristol
parce que ce sont celles qui aujourd'hui
guide le pays le plus puissant du monde
on pourrait résumer ça dans la pax
americana c'est à dire la paix
américaine est en gros c'est pour que la
démocratie soit en sécurité il faut
qu'elle s'étende à l'ensemble de la
planète voilà quitte pour cela à
utiliser la force et savait que les
états unis ont aujourd'hui une armée qui
est mondialement invincible quitte pour
cela donc à déclencher la quatrième
guerre mondiale puisque pour vous la
troisième c'était la guerre froide la
théorie c'est d'imposer la démocratie
dans le monde entier enfin la démocratie
version américaine dans le monde entier
même par la force
quelquefois il faut effectivement
résister à la résistance par la force et
si on est l'hymne un dictateur et c'est
pour promouvoir la démocratie on va pas
remplacer un dictateur par un autre
alors en fait aujourd'hui d'après vous
ce qui peut arriver de mieux au monde
sait que l'amérique réussisse sa mission
universelle sa mission civilisatrice
[Applaudissements]
effectivement beaucoup de pays de cette
façon on peut servir à compans même à
l'arabie saoudite
ou aux ya effectivement des gens qu'on
aimerait bien libérer malheureusement
bien souvent nous ne pouvons pas
intervenir il faut pas alors qu'on va
essayer de redresser des dictateurs
quand le dictateur nous menace nous une
menace la région la quelquefois il faut
quand même y est ce que c'est parce que
vous avez fait avec les indiens du
far-west finalement vous leur avez
apporté la démocratie mais vous avez
tous tués quand même non
il ya eu d injustice terrible de paix
mis m les indiens d'amérique de même
contre les noirs des états unis de tous
les pays ont des histoires d'injustice
je crois que c'est incontestable mais je
suis néanmoins fier d'être américain et
pour vous il n'y a pas d'autre solution
que d'accepter ce que vous appelez
l'hégémonie bienveillant de l'est des
états unis c'est la seule solution pour
le monde aujourd'hui un petit peu comme
comme le servent au moyen-âge accepter
l'hégémonie bienveillante de son
seigneur encore je n'exige pas que la
france nous suivent la france a le droit
d'être en désaccord avec l'amérique tout
à l'heure nous avons parlé de cette
parodie de la marseillaise la faut voir
que la dernière page du wiki stander qui
est le vrai journal c'est une page qui
s'appelle par dizaines et des pastilles
chanter bon ouais
c'est au tajine ou réfectoire ses
parodies de marc séguin d'un treuil nous
les français si vous voulez on a déjà
essayé
d'exporter la démocratie on a déjà
essayé d'exporter l'esprit des lumières
les principes de 89 on l'a fait ça
s'appelait la colonisation n'est parti
dans tous les pays du monde pour leur
expliquer que ça allait aller très bien
s'il était démocrate ça n'a pas marché
ils nous ont viré au nom des principes
qu'on leur avait enseigné d'ailleurs
souvent est-ce que vous pensez que
l'amérique ne se prédispose pas au même
refus en exportant ses valeurs un peu de
force dans le monde entier
si l'irak devient et démocratie et nous
disent eh bien merci l'amérique
maintenant parts et nous serons ravis de
partir de même que les états unis ont
quitté la france après la deuxième
guerre mondiale un camp de gaulle a
demandé à l'otan de quitter la france et
bien nous sommes partis sans problème il
y à des dictatures où il faut réagir
nous sommes pas d'accord sur la façon de
réagir mais cette rhétorique sur l'
empire américain
c'est refait tout ça je crois qu'on
s'éloigne de la réalité le monde ne
fonctionne pas de cette façon certes le
des états unis sont le pays le plus
puissant du monde c'est incontestable ce
qui nous donne des responsabilités
particulières notamment comme vous
l'indiquez le droit et l'obligation de
ce service bien éric leurent je veux
dire vous saviez pas que william
question était là ce soir quand vous
avez lu la parodie de la marseillaise
dans le weekly standard eu ce cri stoll
déteste on est chez les je le disais
tout à l'heure les faibles et pauvres
qui va l'aider thierry t il vraiment il
n'aime pas du tout est vraiment il
milite vraiment vraiment vraiment
pourquoi
je pense
posé sur et enfin de muscu quelque part
monsieur christol qui nous a fait tout
ce
qui est tout à fait étonnant c'est que
vous même vous êtes un assist et
monsieur bristol parce que vous votre
journal est financé par financé par
rupert murdoch totalement par une
manière de la presse ultraconservateur
qui en effet dit une ligne précise
probablement vous êtes en effet sur la
chaîne fox news qui ressemble en effet
donc je vais dire mérite amplement à
l'information réelle autant qu'une
chaîne par exemple télévision du
cannabis voilà
mais attendez attendez non ce que je
vois pour une fois qu'on a un
néoconservateur c'est le premier qu'on a
c'est le premier qui peut s'expliquer en
france à la télévision je reconnais
jamais vu d'autres sinon du plach donc
soyez gentils ne très fort des williams
la gueule ouais
alors là moi je ne sais même pas par où
commencer
c'est une telle caricature que l'on est
en train de faire de mes propres
positions et de celle des néo
conservateurs c'est vraiment la version
caricaturale c'est comme s'est passé
comme si on faisait un portrait
complètement débile de la france adhère
aux états unis il ya un peu de tout de
la route et a fini dans les journaux
américains c'est le même genre de chant
et que c'est du même niveau c'est comme
si on commençait à croire à ces
sornettes
on peut dire que je déteste des pauvres
que je pense que mes politiques ne des
politiques américaines ne vont pas aider
les pauvres
je suis certes conservateur jeu j'en ai
je n'en rougis pas mais tout le reste
c'est vraiment de la caricature il
suffit de regarder la chaîne
effectivement foxnews pour en effet voir
l'ampleur de la caricature
n'importe quelle personne par exemple
durant la guerre du golfe ou avant
l'affairé du golf qui émettait la
moindre réticence quant au bien fondé de
cette intervention ou quant à la
politique étrangère américaine était met
littéralement insulté c'était monsieur
vraiment monsieur christol il suffit de
regarder tout ça c'était à chasse aux
sorcières réellement
le weekly standard que je m'habille et
indépendants sur le plan politique je ne
sais pas toujours d'accord avec rupert
murdoch qui d'ailleurs ne nous dicte pas
notre ligne de pensée alors on peut
critiquer le journal ne peut pas dire ça
c'est dur doit que les propriétaires
ergo c'est un journal c'est un torchon
l'extrême droite la fox news a jouer un
rôle utile aux états unis pour apporter
un point de vue différent à la
télévision il y avait d'ailleurs souvent
des émissions dédiées pas et vous
trouvez maintenant mais ce christol que
les propos par exemple de cette parodie
de la marseillaise sont d'une grande
qualité vraiment et d'amour ou
la parodie de la marseillaise
et de fond c'est aux autres de juger les
techniques 48 art aux différents
certaines parodies sont plus drôles que
d'autres oui
c'est terrible parce que j'ai
l'impression c'est horrible j'ai
l'impression qu'avec les américains là
on vous voyant peut-être parce que c'est
vous j'ai l'impression qu'on se comprend
plus qu'on parle plus de la même chose
c'est que ça qu'on avait quelque chose
en commun jusqu'au 11 septembre
effectivement nous sommes peut-être
éloigné depuis le 11 septembre
nous avons été attaqués nous avons réagi
peut-être que nous avons trop réagi je
ne sais pas c'est une résolution mais il
ne faut pas se dire que si bas s'il y
avait eu un président démocrate serait
très même chose si al khor avait été élu
serait aux galeries clinton a voté pour
la guerre en irak et là elle a soutenu
proche et donc c'était une solution
bipartisane aux états unis démocrates et
républicains nous avions pu shooter tous
tort mais l'avenir nous le dira je
reviendrai peut-être dans deux ans on
verra si nous avons eu raison quand même
si la situation en irak s'est vraiment
détérioré ici les armes de destruction
massive se sont déployés partout
peut-être été grimé
mais j'espère j'espère que les choses
iront mieux les armes de destruction
massive pour le moment les trouve par un
nom mais j'espère je pense qu'on finira
par les trouver est ce que vous
comprenez est ce que vous comprenez
william kristol qu'aujourd'hui pour nous
français les états unis qu'on a
considéré un peu comme notre grand frère
les gens qui sont venus nous ont sauvés
deux fois la mise 1 contre les allemands
à deux fois est ce que vous comprenez
qu'aujourd'hui on ait peur de vous on a
l'impression qu'à la tête de votre pays
il ya un type qui est prêt à faire à peu
près n'importe quoi on a peur
je peux comprendre cela ça fait quelques
jours que je suis ici je lis la presse
française je crois comprendre la
situation peut-être que là c'est la
diplomatie a échoué de notre côté mais
il faut quand même pas exagérer ce qu'a
fait ce qu'on fait les occasions nous
avons mené la guerre en afghanistan pour
nous débarrasser des talibans nous avons
mené notre guerre pour vous débarrasser
de saddam hussein l'avenir nous dira si
nous avions eu raison temps je pense que
nous avons fait ce qu'il fallait
au proche orient après c'est sûr c'est
que vous vous décidez ce sera la
conclusion vous vous décidé d'intervenir
dans un certain nombre de pays en disant
voilà celui là il nous plaît pas on fait
une guerre préventive vous avait
réintroduit l'idée de guerre préventive
nous on a la suprématie militaire on
intervient où on veut dans le monde pour
régler les affaires du monde est ce que
vous comprenez que vous vous érigée en
gendarme du monde
comprenant le pétrole de la plaine au
passage
peut-être que quelquefois le monde le
monde a besoin d'agents tard
ac oui disons que si nous intervenons
dix fois dans les dix années à venir et
que nous commençons à éliminer des
démocraties à causer des déceptions dans
le monde or là évidemment je serais
content que ce soit à venir bilquez sur
vous l'avez déjà fait quand vous quand
vous virer allende pour mettre pinochet
au chili vous attaquez une démocratie
l'universel il avait vous l'avait délogé
donc mais bien géré
je n'étais pas un nouveau conservateur
reconnu à l'époque c'était un bon choix
ou non mais là
décembre 41 on a appris qu'on ne peut
pas simplement attendre sur attaquer et
l'amérique a attendu trop longtemps
avant de réagir à la deuxième gamme et
la période de la guerre froide et la
même chose au cours des dix dernières
années des années 90 depuis la fin de la
guerre froide on a remarqué qu'à
l'amérique était trop lente ils n'ont
pas trop rapide le 11 septembre a été un
cri d'alarmé et je crois que maintenant
nous pourrons peser chaque cas à sa
valeur j'espère qu'on n'aura pas besoin
militaires les américains aiment aller
faire la guerre et push n'aime pas
envoyer des boys des soldats américains
faire la guerre oui il y a tout de même
chose troublante il y avait quand même
un ordre international il existait en et
c'est donc un organisme de concertation
qui était nommé nu il n'y avait aucune
urgence à déclencher ce conflit les
nations unies
ont simplement regarder des gens se
faire tuer au palco au rwanda les
nations unies peut-être sont une idée
noble mais ne savent pas sauver des vies
merci beaucoup merci c'était courageux
d'être venu en france
ça de l'année
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
lardy tube abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu